[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber police in Massachusetts
are expanding their search for a missing
Mother after finding some pretty
chilling clues in the home that her
family was renting near Boston and
during those searches investigators
reportedly found trash bags with blood a
hatchet a hacksaw a rug and of course
used Cleaning Supplies on Tuesday police
searched several waste and recycling
facilities in Southeastern Massachusetts
Anna Walsh was last seen on New Year's
Day on January 3rd she she was supposed
to be on a flight to her job with a real
estate firm in Washington DC but she
never showed up and no one has heard
from her ever since her employer was
actually the one to report her missing
now police arrested her husband Brian
Walsh on Monday accusing him of
misleading police he was already
awaiting sentencing in a federal case
where he tried to sell fake Andy Warhol
paintings on eBay Walsh wasn't supposed
to leave his home without permission but
police discovered that not only did he
leave on January 2nd he went to a home d
Depot store and spent more than four
hundred dollars in cash buying cleaning
supplies according to police they found
blood as well as a bloody knife in the
basement of the home where the Walsh
family was renting and we've also
learned that Walsh allegedly Googled how
to dispose of a 115 pound woman's body
he's not been charged in connection with
his wife's disappearances of yet but
Walsh is being held in 500 000 bond for
allegedly deceiving the cops the Walsh's
three children are now in the custody of
the Department of Children and Family
Services
so I have my two my two co-hosts were
with me today defense attorney Brian
buckmeyer former trial Attorney Terry
Austin Brian we have seen murder cases
where bodies not found do you think at
this point there's enough circumstantial
evidence here for a murder charge I
think they just need one more thing and
that's to test the DNA in the blood
that's found in the basement as well as
on the knife if that matches for Anna
Walsh then I think they have everything
because make it at least saying we're
going to get an indictment here but in
this case I think there's no rush that
half a million dollar bail for deceiving
the police that's not deceiving police
bail that's homicide bail and I think
they know they have enough information
they're holding on to him because they
don't want him to disturb any evidence
or try to get rid of it anyway I think
they could take their time here and
collect more evidence as they move along
because he's not going anywhere with a
state case or the federal case Terry if
they bring murder charges is there
anything you see about motive at this
point well I don't think it's if I think
it's when they are going to bring those
murder charges it's just too much
evidence against this sky but I do see a
possible motive oftentimes when you have
the spouse they're going to look for a
triangle a love triangle or they're
going to look for some Financial motive
I don't see either one of those yet but
here's what I'm thinking so far just
based on the little bit we know that
eBay selling that he was doing was on
her eBay account maybe he wanted to make
sure she didn't repeat anything maybe
she knew about it and so he tried to
silence her right now I think that might
be a motive but again you know you don't
have to prove a mode if you just have to
prove that he intended to kill her and I
think they have enough for that we still
don't have a lot of information but I'll
tell you what this is we've seen cases
like this before and usually it is not a
great end
in Newport News Virginia We are
following updates on Friday shooting at
richneck elementary school where a
six-year-old boy fired a shot at a
teacher during class and we now know
that the weapon that was involved was
owned by the boy's mother police say the
young student used a nine millimeter
handgun in the targeted shooting of 25
year old Abigail's Werner officials
revealed in a press conference that it
was legally purchased by the boy's
mother and was in their family home the
boy bought the gun or brought the gun I
should say to school in his backpack
official said zwerner put her hand up in
a defensive position when the shot was
fired and it went through her hand and
into her upper chest she's currently in
a hospital but it's said to be that
she's improving the police chief
detailed the status of the suspect and
what's next in the legal process
detectives talk with human services and
child protective services are
commonwealth attorney's office I've
talked to Mr Gwen several times as late
as last night in this afternoon
the community service board which is a
which addresses mental and Behavioral
Health
due to the age of the child we made
these conversations these contacts and
conversations to seek guidance on
possible services
because none of us have a lot of
information dealing with something like
this a community service board
determined that a temporary detention
order would be obtained from a
magistrate and the child is currently
receiving treatment at a medical
facility as far as charges against
family members parents once the
information right once all the
interviews have been conducted all is
the gentleman behind you just asked
about if the parents said anything once
all that stuff is obtained we know what
we know from Human Services or Child
Protective Services what information the
schools have the other interviews that
we still need I'd like the detectives
want to go back and have some more
conversation with Abigail we will
present that and sit down with the
Commonwealth attorney's office they will
review that and and a great comment he
made to me today
was
where the facts are
and what the law supports will determine
if there will be any charges but I would
be I would be wrong to to make that
statement now it'll be where the
investigation leads
well we'll continue to follow the case
here on Long crime daily and of course
provide you more updates as they surface
while we now know prosecutors will retry
that 70 show star Danny Masterson after
a jury deadlocked at the end of last
year on rape charges jurors weren't able
to reach a unanimous verdict in November
and Masterson's defense team filed to
have the three charges dismissed but the
judge denied that and scheduled a new
trial to start in March Masterson is
charged with raping three women
including a former girlfriend between
2001 and 2003 at his home in the
Hollywood Hills all three accusers are
ex-scientologists and are suing
Masterson as well as the Church of
Scientology in Civil Court as well Flo
Rida is suing Celsius Holdings which
makes Celsius energy drinks the Platinum
selling artist says that Celsius owes
him money that he was supposed to make
as part of an endorsement deal Flo Rida
served as a brand ambassador to help the
drink maker launch in 2014 and grow from
there Flo Rida and two companies that
helped him broker the deal were supposed
to get payments when Celsius reached
certain benchmarks but his legal team
says that those extra royalties were
never paid a jury for the case was sworn
in on Tuesday afternoon
plaintiffs claimed that the defendants
breached contractual obligations by
failing to pay compensation owed to
plaintiffs and that plaintiffs have
incurred resulting damages
defendant denies that it breached any
contract and claims that it does not owe
plaintiffs any additional compensation
Terry you're our Civil Trial law expert
what do you think about it you know you
might remember if Florida's very popular
song Sometimes I get a good feeling well
there are no good feelings in this case
so for the most part civil cases can be
broken down into two types first breach
of contract or a breach of a tort at a
tort is just another word for a duty
owed to someone else so negligence is
the most common one and it's a tort
because the defendant breached a duty of
care to someone else this case is a very
simple contract dispute which should
make the outcome fairly straightforward
most contract disputes can be decided by
the information contained in the four
corners of that contract but the terms
of this contract they weren't so clear
fluoride is claiming that as the brand
ambassador he should have profited when
the company profited he claims that he
took the company from a one dollar per
share company to a 98 per share but the
contract refers to units instead of
shares and it doesn't really specify any
cutoff dates so there could have also
have been an unfair advantage and a jury
is going to have to figure that out
Brian based on what Terry said what do
you think the jury is going to decide
with fluoride or Celsius all right so
hear me I haven't done contract law
since my first year of law school many
many moons ago but from what I
understand the drafter of the contract
usually has the information read against
them so when Terry talks about units or
shares if Celsius energy holding or
Celsius holding sorry is someone who
drafted the contract any ambiguity may
be read against them and if you're
asking me I don't know who's going to
improve whose brand more Flowrider or
sales I need to drink I've never heard
of Celsius energy drink I mean I'm
Canadian I know how to use celsius but
flowrite is probably the one who
actually brought more profit to this
company so I think the jury May lean
more into his side because of name
recognition especially in the community
that this case is going in yeah you guys
need to switch from Celsius it just gets
way too complicated we don't do
everything perfect here hey you guys
gotta switch I know boiling point and
freezing point okay better than me
better than me